[Music]
you got predator coming in you got
predator you got predator
guys there's german over here dumb ass
eyes is that you yes
we're almost to the next station you
know how i know
no no cause i can see it
[Music]
you're missing everything
yeah i missed a lot of things you're mr
grab man i just want the goopy whoopies
why do you want the goopies because they
feel good in my pockets
ah that's what happens that's what you
get
well that's because your storage is full
well we're gonna have more
we're gonna have so much more metal
would have won
just be patient hey hey mark yeah what's
up uh come over here okay
i just want you to have this
oh what i don't i got it
i've dropped an iron and it started
falling off the thing yeah we're moving
it's fine it's fine this is fine we're
fine it's fine it's like you hand me an
entire stack of metal and
there it goes
my entire life flashed before my entire
eyes you gotta go back there was metal
babies
we're coming in to dock
i like docking and i like things in my
pockets i like grabbing i like docking i
like things in my life i've never talked
while grabbing
no i haven't actually you should
oh
incoming not moving now
incoming incoming
someone's shooting i'm aware
oh i see from over there
that did not do very much damage okay i
have 16 health i don't know if gunfight
is the right thing for me right now guys
yeah uh be careful oh man they came
around from behind
so many
yeah oh watch out who on the left up top
i'm falling back even harder
wow oh i killed one guys i killed one
what did he drive he dropped a token
he's got a token we can go gambling we
can gamble
oh my god i got guys like running around
at 100 miles an hour over here also he's
not taking damage he's invincible
this is invisible oh you're shooting
waves invincible
you scared me i was charged that you
think there was someone behind me but
you were shooting me yeah i was shooting
you yeah i got a token oh
hell yeah
hey i got a token
ladies and gentlemen our
yeah i got another
module i picked up a revolver module oh
that sounds uh there's a this one won't
die
i missed every shot i shot completely
around his skull
wait where is he is he invincible oh i
found him he's dead invincible he's dead
he's events new gun he's very vinci he's
invincible you guys are like wizards i
keep going to new places and you keep
being there before me
that's how we do baby
we must be invincible
oh mark is this our new trolley train
car sure is my friend's watch wow look
how wait
what wait what what in the middle of the
battle in the fires of war
can i fire my load into your ass bob
no
no okay no do we need wooden floor we do
need wooden floor to build we need one
floor yeah but who wants to gamble
where are you gambling at there's a slot
machine uh near the train uh towards oh
that's bigger than i would have thought
look guys train we got new boxes on the
train bigger than you would have thought
yeah that's bigger
i can't grab any of this [ __ ] i'm
spinning
that looks okay i got one token back
nice you got the clover
monster [ __ ]
yeah
thank you thank you
leaf monster [ __ ] dude thank you are you
gambling or what wood i don't have any
tokens do you go for it boom
oh oh oh oh oh i got my token back i
guess wait i got three tokens what the
hell
oh yeah two wow
i got a log
[Laughter]
okay i have a lot more tokens
well i'm gonna keep getting more tokens
are good
wow
anyone else want to gamble should i
spread this around no no no no go for it
man dude
three more tokens
[Music]
okay uh that's terrifying i've made
floor boys
look at the boxes
is one like ammo recipe
uh purple glowing
rifled [ __ ]
and uh one of the ten commandments from
uh
moses or whatever okay
yep you got it three lizards you get a
you get one of the ten commandments hey
who took my medal i just who the hell
took my medal do you want it back i
would love it back
this first set of water dirty ice for
you a water bladder over there
it's a it's a it's a it's a canteen
i researched a throwing ring
so we don't have to swim
oh hell yeah dude
all right how in the hell do we get more
do we get open up the other slots in
these stupid boxes that's what they want
so one thing you guys don't know about
is over here this table with the the
blueprint i researched something earlier
oh
oh yeah he researched the thingy for the
thingy that we needed
the cur the cardigan ah okay okay
interesting
interesting very interesting interesting
interesting okay so the throw ring is
like a consumable right our progression
mission is craft 10 of them which means
we need 10 metal to make them because
they're like one metal a piece
so i don't know why it's that much but
i'm assuming they'll exponentially
increase our ability to get metal you
know what i'm saying is it iron or
copper iron and then eventually we'll
need to keep researching but not right
now
i'm making them
i don't have any more fuel oh i made
five in one so i i've done it i did our
progress oh okay
all right i'm going i'm go here we go
ready three two one
yeah
uh sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey we got so much more space now
i know right see this is what patience
gives us
okay hello ah look at this extra
yeah right
yeah just uh
i just got a little jump scared by
flying
further backwards than i thought i was
going to when i was walking on my feet
all right i don't know how the throwing
ring works and i'm going to experiment
with it
you used like a consumable then you
throw it
what the hell was that
what the hell was that
maybe you catch creatures with it or
something
i what
what
big big is coming
what we need a winch that's right we
need to research the winch because
there's something about the rings for
the world
shockingly everybody we need more metal
more metal unbelievable
i don't think i'm connected or something
my rope's gone
wait
don't help me
how do we help you
stop the trick get out wade jesus
my ropes is invisible
i just swam back to the train it's
possible just swim i'm swimming
so what happened with the ring mark
nothing uh you need a winch for it
oh
wait swim faster come on now
why are you out of breath you just call
me oh lychees
oh [ __ ] who nailed it
i'd like to think that wade has a setup
over his computer that's all motion
controls so he has a physically swim to
move
mark did you just not gather this wood
or does that not literally
i went out there didn't have the space
and i was just gonna quietly keep that
to myself
i just saw that and i was like
he clearly was going for that exact
thing
don't even mind it oh
you guys don't don't worry nobody
noticed don't know what don't look
forward don't look what no no it's fine
oh um i thought these like eyeball nut
sacks ah
oh that thing
yeah um
what do we shoot it okay
oh i shot it no i'm fine we're fine it's
a weird little like
uh penetrative hole in the top
it's like an eyeball okay i researched
winch whatever that means how do we
build a win isn't that the term for a
bark keeper who gives the whale we have
a winch
oh [ __ ] i cannot winch myself to things
okay so you see this yeah this is where
the hook comes in right so we throw a
ring for the hook and then we can winch
out to it i can't just winch to anything
that i desire no we can get to abandon
trains in the void i don't know what
that means and travel deep into the void
in certain places by
oh oh we missed the metal i'm gonna try
a thing okay
everyone wish me luck
okay if i go out here
hold q
yeah
hang on
so you're going to throw a thingy out
there
why didn't you warn me
why didn't you warn me
it gets moved in from outside of our
line of sight what do you mean
we swooped in it that was as shocking to
us as it was
oh you were looking right now
yeah
the throwing ring didn't make it all the
way out to the island unfortunately one
of our things got damaged it told us to
repair it but i don't know how to repair
it i did it already i did it already oh
okay you used your hair is there a leech
on the left side
not that i see
okay i thought i saw a leech maybe i'm
crazy
oh i can get back to the train quickly
huh
can you oh can you grapple back to the
oh yeah middle mouse maybe i need to use
these things as like stepping stones oh
i jumped off the train and did not
attach to it i've done that um oh hey
i'm back
hey guys did you fall
i fell for a while and now i'm back now
good to have you back we need to build a
nest for with limo i was thinking of a
nest for nemo
refleemo
flemo
guys we have a boy we have way too much
[ __ ] right now guys oh yeah how did we
fill up all of our baskets already
i'm making more iron because i have a
whole [ __ ] ton of of the things you guys
see any kind of like train something in
the distance something
fanciful like not really
it said something about abandoning the
islands
that one looks a lot closer than the one
you looked at before yeah wait let me
back up yeah you want to try it yeah i'm
gonna try it i need like a rock i can
attach it to first you know what i'm
saying oh i know what you're saying okay
i'm throwing the ring
okay it bounced right off well that's
not helpful okay that must not be what
we need to go for can you [ __ ] get
off of me
who me you who were standing right
inside me wait what about this i wasn't
until you backed into me
yeah well that you were right inside
you're right you're [ __ ] right up
against get out of here
for me
[Music]
guys i'm going to stop and eat food [ __ ]
you guys what's wrong with you mark all
right guys where are you mark oh i see
you
what's up man
what's going on
the rings i told you you can go far
oh how far can i go
guys i'm just going to see how far i can
go
i'm with you buddy let's do this
together oh god you're out here too
yeah just follow my rings
what is it one iron to make the thing
yeah you make it five should be some
sitting on the workbench wait come on
i know it's there oh it's right there
yeah i can see it oh no is it too far i
don't i think it might just be too far
and let me try to throw one maybe a
little closer
maybe on the north side why don't we go
to the like island
is there anything valuable there can i
grab to them can i throw it to the
island i can try
oh no it bounces right off unfortunately
um yeah well we're out here now we are
out here now i have a ring that's
floating right in the middle of nothing
oh i can pick up the rings i'm gonna go
this way i'm gonna go back
hey mark i can't reach this oh
i can't tell what's happening
oh my god this is terrifying
i hate everything this does have a kind
of feeling of being out in the ocean you
know we had talked about that
i'm back
oh hey what's up dude hey that was uh i
can kind of believe you made it back
yeah hey you researched something nice
man nice all right two of those three
things are researched
awesome ammo
wait what do we need ammo would we have
infinite ammo there
we got this bang bang here
that's all i care about
i imagine if we find like an abandoned
train out in the wilderness it's gonna
have lots of resources like pre-made
stuff it's going to be
probably it's going to be primo guys
look down below there's like space
pyramids
oh yeah like some destiny too
yeah that this place does have a very
destiny feel to it i have the music all
the huey oohs is very destiny-ish yeah
space opera ass thing
where's all the wood
why don't these asteroids have much wood
on them i don't know i think if i shoot
stuff it should give me
resources i feel like that's actually
probably something that will happen in
the future like we're able to just smash
them harvesting with my god i heard a
sclerp what's this what's that sclerp
sound squirt what do you use
like a monstery slurp got that guy you
thought you could hide you could not
i'm sorry did you just take credit for
killing that guy
that i clearly killed i killed a
different guy
i clearly killed me for you even it's
not me no there's no i killed it it's
not funny
sure oh okay yeah no you killed him i
killed someone i don't know who you
killed i believe that we killed dude
very much people
i believe that we're both murderers any
debate that i killed that guy
i killed that guy and i'll say it in
front of anyone
but you can't debate because you don't
know the rules of debate
oh what are the rules what are the rules
uh rule number one the keeper of the
rules is the only one i shall know the
rules rule number two i'll tell you if
you break them
that's why i debate so hard i want i'm
gonna tell the nerdiest story i've ever
told in my life i was uh
trying out for colleges
and uh i was going to rose holman
i was just going to see different
colleges and visiting the campuses
um and so i was at rose holmen and i was
with some of the people there and we
played that card game where they don't
you can't talk because talking is
against rules and every time you break a
rule you have to draw a card so no one
can tell you the rules but you have to
learn it by making mistakes
and uh i i lost the first game and then
by the second game i beat everyone
because i picked up all the rules and i
was a genius so i didn't know the rules
no they knew the rules and that's how
much better i am at them than that than
that thing oh if you asked me to play
right now i would never even frickin
know what the [ __ ] rules were but god
i was smart back then i really became
stupid god no mine i got it it was mine
i saw it wade got it i got it's in my
inventory
looks like we're coming up on a pit stop
here all right we're gonna have to
murder some a-holes or whatever i hope
so then we get more tokens all right i'm
gonna research this laptop
oh yeah we need more storage so badly
yeah they've been full forever
oh
we can make a garden hang on we're gonna
have a garden boys
boys we're gonna have a garden
i love the music very dramatic
but i love it
give some importance to it
it really is good like
epic music yeah
oh
oh boys and girls we got ourselves a
garden happening uh i might need to be
right back sorry
okay don't let him kill me
try not to how did i only get one water
flask i put like 50 ice on this
who's moaning at this
[Music]
you know moans happen
around me those happen a lot
what do you mean
i don't know i was just talking out of
my butt guys am i alone hello hey still
alive
yeah you're still alive oh thank god
enemies enemies enemies enemies enemies
enemies enemies
oh no you're not
why would i be joking why would i be
joking hey
bad time to be drinking water from my
flask watch out for the invincible ones
all right
he's groaning he's grunting ow i'm being
very shot i'm very shot oh nailed him
head out shot i've been shot i'll be
dead
he's invincible oh that's you
see it's scary isn't it it's a little
scary
don't hide behind a box get over here
one of these dudes is hiding behind him
oh hey what's up
how's it going
hey not bad oh you can melee guys did
you know you can melee how do you make a
melee button f
f oh i want to f some people melee oh
all right well well done boys
we
i wasn't even picking up tokens so all
the guys i killed on the like right side
of the train i don't know if they've
dropped stuff or what i would love to
know what the deal is with the tables
the weird sacrifice tables
there's definitely some lore because
like this whole area like this platform
this ethereal universe like
i
there's some lore here you're saying you
think there's some sort of explanation
or something i think that eventually if
you dig deep enough you might be able to
find one
that's fair that's fair where's the
gambling gambling same spot gamble
[Applause]
get with the jackpot all right
your turn
all right
nice right i'm drinking my hands okay
i've got a couple tokens here we go
oh triple double triple clover coins
and more wood all right
oh no maybe you need more wood
maybe it needs more mud
that [ __ ] guy
woman
[ __ ] all right
yeah just reliving past
i've moved on
sure sure sure yeah sure all right i'm
building a reflemo nest
oh bill what's up oh god damn it i built
it the wrong goddamn go my god it's
backwards
mark you idiot oh it's backwards god
that seems really inconvenient just
deconstruct it with your hammer does it
give everything back that does did you
give it everything back all the
resources no
relocate one wood okay relocating it
there we go
bam
how you like that
pretty good right pretty good pretty
good pretty good pretty good pretty good
very nice buddy very nice pretty good
pretty good all right i don't know what
reflemo do
but uh reflemo
reef limo
yup hey
cook it
nice
i'm out of tokens we have so much
[ __ ] stuff everywhere i know i know
maybe reflamo goes and fetches things
for us do you think that i hope so yeah
probably that'd be nice uh where are we
putting the basic frame the gun parts
basically i've been carrying them
because everything has been full
that's fair it is very full uh how much
barbecue do you guys have barbecue
barbecue grilled organics how much of
that do you got
i am officially out but there's two
organics in this box that aren't cooked
there's ten in this one that aren't
cooked okay i need uh five to do the
next level of research
you need five grilled or god damn you
got a lot of the green goop
yeah we have so much [ __ ] chemicals
unending supply of the green why did you
pick up so much green why is this taking
up so much of our inventory
yeah i'm chucking it we don't need this
how many how many grilled organics do
you need mark uh five total i have
one right now
i have
one and i'm crafting five we've been
through a lot together
i'm i'm also trucking some of this
stupid green [ __ ] oh come on is that all
you gathered wade it's literally oh my
god there's an entire chest of green
shirts i know why
please guys why come on anyway you guys
ready to rock i want to rock
yeah
shut up
oh i thought i thought wade fell off the
back
would you have stopped nah i couldn't no
we just would have laughed about it
all right i'm researching satiaty one
i don't know what that did
sounds like a food thing grappling hook
again now why is everything a grappling
hook with you
but it's different it's a different
thing
what is it then i don't know it's
different
well read it or whatever where where
it is
that's what it says this is grappling
hook
oh yeah i need some of that green [ __ ]
do we have did you throw all of it okay
good oh there's metal we left behind
oh there's more metal we've left behind
so much metal we'll go get you want me
to back up you want to back up dude you
want me to back up i'll back up metal
metal fly off into
honestly we're not exactly short on
metal right now yeah we do have a lot of
metal wood's the one thing i keep
running out of yeah what is the thing we
absolutely need to get some wood yeah
what is what is
not prevalent
one one of these
considering how many islands there are
with huge [ __ ] trees on them
all disappointed in the amount of wood
we're getting well just you wait because
we're about to have a grappling hook
boys good does that give me wood
i don't know
alright get ready get ready get ready
your lives are about to change
[Music]
bye